welcome back to 8701
so we continue our discussion of nuclear
physics and in this lecture
we talk about the nuclear force now
in the last lecture we saw that nuclei
bound together and we were able to
calculate
using an empirical model the binding
energy of various
nuclei now the question remains what is
actually
binding those nucleis together
if you remember i mean in the first
weeks and months of this lecture we
looked about and looked and discussed
various interactions between elementary
particles we saw the
electromagnetic interactions the weak
interaction and the strong interactions
there was no discussion of the nuclear
interaction or the nuclear force now
what is this
we have seen that the strong force act
acts between quarks
in head runs for example we have
discussed at length
the pion
the pion which is made up of an up quark
and a down quark and those are hold
together or bound together
via the strong force and we look also at
the structure of a proton and the
structure of a neutron
now the nuclear force is the residual
interaction between the quarks localized
in different atoms so the interactions
between for example this up quark here
and the down quark here in a different
nuclei
you can already understand that it will
be difficult to have a full
understanding
of the nuclear force why because
it is many quarks involved and there's
many
protons and nucleons involved in this
process
so what we find is later that we can
describe this using a mean field
approach a mean field of
forces between the particles involved
so what is the experimental status our
understanding of the nuclear force is
based on
various kinds of experimental
information
the first comes from nucleon nucleon
proton proton neutron neutron and proton
neutron scattering experiments
and some of those experiments have the
benefit of using
spin polarized projectiles for example a
polarized
electron being used to probe the
structure
of a nucleus nuclear binding energies we
have seen those again
and the position measurement of masses
they give us insight
especially useful for the lightning of
the eye and the nuclear structure
information such as
energies energy levels spin
parities magnetic and quadruple moments
again especially of the light nuclei and
there's many more to be named in more
detail
um but conceptually those are the three
kind of pieces of information we have
the experiment those experimental
results
indicate that the nuclear force depends
on the distance between the interacting
nucleons
this is the radial part how far apart
are those neutrons
and also the spin and angular momentum
of the interacting nucleus there it
seems to be a spin
orbit and also a tensor part when it
comes to the nuclear force
it is also interesting to note and we'll
talk about this
more as it there doesn't seem to be any
indication that the nuclear force
depends on the type of nucleon whether
or not it's a proton
or a neutron in the interaction
so there's charge independence
so looking at the radial part of this
the nuclear force is short range
uh which implies it vanishes for
distances
longer than about two empty meters so it
basically vanishes in this area here and
the nuclear force is strongly repulsive
for distances
shorter than about 0.5 in this area
femtometers you can understand the
repulsiveness by the fact that
you cannot really push or press an
existing
nucleon are further than its its actual
radius you cannot
compress them further this is also kind
of
uh apparent in the in the
in the uh liquid drop model where we
discussed you know
a volume term and the volume is not
cannot be compressed further the other
on the other hand
you saw that there's short range
distance in fact
because we find this linearity with the
the mass number in the binding energies
right so here the arguments the binding
energies per nuclear which is roughly
constant indicates that the nucleons and
nuclei interact only in the immediate
neighbors
right otherwise you could have an a
square term or an a times a minus
one term in there and then the
measurement of distances between the
nuclei and which nuclear reactions start
to occur
those are in the order of one to two
femtometer
larger than the corresponding ready
radii the nuclear densities which are
only slightly smaller than the nuclear
densities in
indicating very dense packing so again
they're already very
densely packed you cannot push them
much further
on the spin orbit force here that's an
area where we could go into much more
detail but
for this introductory class we don't we
will not um
the scattering of spin polarized
nucleons or
other spin nuclei particles allows us to
understand that
nuclear force has a component which
depends on the spin
and the angular momentum of the
interaction
here's a fun fact so the charge
independent or nuclear forces meaning
that it
doesn't really the nuclear force doesn't
really depends on whether or not there's
protons or neutrons
and you can you know i could ask you you
know would you have expected this
would you have expected that there is a
dependence on the charge and the answer
should have been
no because we just learned that the
nuclear force is a remnant of the strong
interaction the strong interaction
doesn't know about electric charges
so the answer needs to be yes
um the charge in the independence of
nuclear force implies that the
electromagnetic
effects are eliminated in this
scattering meaning when you when you
measure um aspect of the nuclear force
you have to be
aware of the fact that there is
electromagnetic interaction and you have
to
kind of try to get them out and that can
be cut can be done by for example
comparing
scatterings of protons and protransport
and the neutrons neutrons and neutrons
we do a comparison carefully and
subtract out the electromagnetic effects
and you see that
force is indeed independent of the
charge
we can make use of this so there's an a
lot of information
behind or experimental techniques which
can
make use of the fact that nuclear forces
are charged independent
but you can for example do a study so
called
mirror nuclear mirror nucleus those are
the ones we
basically revert the n and the z
for the same a so they're basically
mirrors of themselves
in terms of mirroring the protons on the
neutrons examples are
helium-3 and twistium for example
um and those then allow you to you know
study in detail
um those those effects so this heavy
mirror nuclei
inherit heavy mirror nuclei the breaking
effect
and the effect breaking charge
independence of the nuclear force are
strong
and the similar does not hold good
one example where you can study this is
you for example one of those
mirrors is radioactive or
an instable nuclei you can study
the properties of this instable nuclei
by looking
in detail at the mirrored nucleus so
that's a
rather common and interesting way to
study where you definitely array
you cannot just simply you know take
them excite them and study their
properties
simply decay too fast in some cases
here's a table where you see this effect
you see the you know comparison
comparison between the nuclei this
mirror nucleis here there's four pairs
and you see that the binding energy the
net binding energy after removing the
coulomb term
um is very much the same between those
groups those mirrored groups of nuclei
and this table here or this diagram
shows you excitation energies
for two mirrored nuclei and you see that
the
energy levels are pretty much on power
without going into any detail down power
between those two mirrored
nucleis